voyez une chanson qu'on adore tous sur
cet album complètement dutronc qui
s'appelle l'hôtesse de l'air et je vais
te montrer un problème qu'on les
hôtesses de l'air peut être très grave
regarde le délire incident s'est produit
le 12 juin 1991 c'était le premier
depuis huit ans véronique devait se
rendre à la martinique elle n'avait pas
pris l'avion depuis très longtemps
elle portait une prothèse mammaire
depuis deux ans au milieu du vol j'ai
une douleur terrible au niveau de la
poitrine et j'ai pas tout de suite
compris ce qui m'arrivait j'ai d'abord
cru que c'était le coeur qui lâchait
heureusement il y avait un médecin au
cours du vol qui est qui est venu bon il
s'est pas étonné il me s'est dit mais
c'est votre prothèse qui lâche
l'explication serait simple il existe
aujourd'hui deux types de prothèses
toutes deux sont constitués d'une
enveloppe de silicone enveloppe réalisé
par trempage successifs dans un bain de
silicone de différents moule de
différentes tailles certaines prothèses
sont vendus prêts gonflé de silicone
d'autres sont remplies au moment de la
pose d'un liquide physiologique
elle serait mieux acceptée par le corps
humain c'est ce type de prothèse que
porte et véronique le liquide auraient
fait exploser l'enveloppent au cours de
la pressurisation de la cabine comme le
réglage de ces pressurisation ne se fait
pas finement tout au long de la montée
mais par étapes
on a des différences de pressurisation
de vous sentez parfois que vos oreilles
dans les avions quand le réglage et plus
ou moins claires et à partir de là on a
constaté que les ruptures se produisait
au cours d'un vol normal non c'est
hautement invraisemblable parce qu'une
prothèse dans le corps d'une très forte
pression reste
jour c'est toujours le même mater les
mêmes matériaux qui sont en jeu et ses
matériaux sont très élastique comme vous
pouvez le voir est très souple
lorsqu'il accepte de répondre les
fabricants exclu toute possibilité de
défaut de leurs produits
les chirurgiens eux n'ont pas souhaité
se prononcer le marché de la prothèse
mammaire est il est vrai en pleine
expansion seule la compagnie corsair
accepte d'aborder le problème
je pense que ça a dû arriver dans
d'autres compagnies mais ça paraît
tellement aberrant je veux dire que les
compagnies ne veulent pas le voir
beaucoup de compagnies ne veulent pas le
voir le corps médical veut pas en
entendre parler alors qu'il est
responsable donc on va spécifiés ou
passagères de se présenter au personnel
de cabine concrètement nous on va
l'indiqué purement et simplement dans
les billets donc c'est la même chose que
pour les pacemakers s'ils voulaient les
pacemakers on a constaté des incidents
au début des années 70 on a installé des
panneaux de sécurité pour prévenir les
gens et depuis on a plus d'incident
voilà
prothèses mammaires le supporte pas
d'avion s de l'info est de l'intox
jacques dutronc à ton avis je connais
c'est à toi de jouer patrick pour moi
c'est de l'info et toi et moi je pense
que c'est john f ou bombay philippe
alors les prothèses mammaires que se
passe-t-il quand on est dans les avions
tu écoutes c'est de l'intox et
corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
ou